florida's long been a battleground state
this year without a doubt
this is a must-win state for president
trump according to
a new report democrats are now turning
out at a much lower rate than
republicans
in the important county of miami-dade
according to bloomberg quote republicans
currently have a 9.4 percent turnout
advantage in miami-dade county
a place where analysts say that biden
will need a significant margin of
victory to carry the state
here with more florida governor ron
desantis governor good to see you
tell us about miami-dade tell us about
early voting
how do you match this up to say 2016 or
your race
when you were running for governor
so four years ago sean there were 340
000
more registered democrats than
republicans when the president won
now that margin is less than a hundred
and forty thousand we've added two
hundred thousand
net republican registrations we've never
been this close
to the democrats in history number two
we are winning
by about 520 000 republican ballots
over democrat for in-person early voting
a lot of the democrats are going to the
mail
they have an advantage of there but
we're closing the overall
early voting at a much faster rate than
we did in 2016
and then miami-dade's important sean
because the president lost that
by 30 points and still won the state
he's now in a situation with the turnout
we're seeing
he may be able to cut that margin in
half in a county as big as miami-dade
that could be a hundred thousand vote
swing
and i can tell you being down there uh
the cuban-american communities fired up
the venezuelan-americans all the
hispanics
who understand the threat that marxism
poses
they are rallying to donald trump and so
i think that was something he had to do
do better in miami-dade and i'll tell
you i don't think we could have done
any better up to this point i hope it
continues what are the other things that
anecdotally that maybe you're hearing
from the people in florida
such an important swing state uh as it
relates to joe biden
you know mr dark winner doom and gloom
hide in the basement
uh not give answers about packing the
court which i i still to this
day cannot imagine he won't give an
answer to that question
because i think the answer is he will
pack the court and i think he'll be
beholden to the left wing
what what are they saying about how
biden has
hidden basically the whole campaign
well i think it's been an absolute joke
if you look
he doesn't even know who he's running
against sometimes he'll say he's running
for the u.s senate
the other day he talked about george
bush but i think his
lockdown mentality saying he would lock
down the country
does not play well in the state of
florida sean we have all 67 counties
have schools open for in person we have
five of the 10
biggest school districts in the country
all open for in person obviously our
economy is open
people don't want to be locked down
parents want to be able to send their
kid to school
and i think his message the doom and
gloom is not what people want to hear
and i think the president's been much
more optimistic
and i think that that's resonated a lot
more and i also think this just in the
mechanics of voting
the doom and gloom about covet has
shifted democrats to vote
for for mail because they're not
comfortable going in person
well we're going into election day we're
going to have 200
000 more super voters who haven't voted
who we know will show up
so our election day turnout we usually
win election day anyways
i think that margin is going to be even
bigger this year and i think part of
that will be
for some of the fear-mongering that
biden has done i think it's going to
come back to bite them
all right governor great to see you
we'll be watching very closely florida
a great state of florida on tuesday